Welcome to Vanderpump Dogs.
We created this rescue center
and with our incredible team,
we have found homes for more
than two thousand dogs.
This is Hermie.
Mary.
It's like a dating process.
This is Larry.
You wanna have a little foreplay
before you go all the way.
This is Angel.
This is Knight.
This is Violet.
What did you think?
I want three dogs.
That's a lot of
picking up poop.
I'll take one.
The goal is to make these
dogs feel like VIPs.
LVP's VIPs.
A Vanderpuff entails
shampoos, brushouts,
then I go into places
your barber doesn't go.
This is Duke.
Oh my god, that
looks like my husband.
I'm sure I married
you 38 years ago.
We have to be sure
that this is the best
option for the dog.
I feel ready for it.
It's not about just finding
somebody attractive
across the bar.
This isn't a one-night stand.
This is a life-long relationship.
I am just so happy that he's
going to be my forever dog.
I couldn't have asked
for anything better.